en este vídeo ahora tenemos tres grandes
bloques llamaremos este un gran bloque
dos y tres en el que en cada uno tenemos
24 pelotas verdes ustedes pueden pausar
el vídeo y contarlas si así lo desean y
el objetivo de este vídeo es que ustedes
vean cómo podemos llegar a este mismo
número 24 por diferentes caminos y esto
a través de la multiplicación vamos a
empezar con este primer conjunto que
tenemos en color morado y también vemos
aquí con color azul que está uniendo
algunas de estas pelotas así es que
contemos aquí tenemos aquí tenemos un
primer conjunto de cuatro pelotas un
segundo conjunto de cuatro pelotas y
este es el tercer conjunto de cuatro
pelotas tenemos tres veces cuatro
pelotas en este primer bloque morado en
este segundo bloque tenemos exactamente
lo mismo tenemos un conjunto de cuatro
pelotas dos conjuntos de cuatro pelotas
tres conjuntos de cuatro pelotas y lo
volveremos a marcar aquí 3
conjuntos de cuatro pelotas o tres por
cuatro tenemos dos veces 3 por 4 3 por 4
una vez 3 por 4 otra vez así es que
vamos a colocarlo como 2 veces
es por cuatro
o lo que es lo mismo dos por tres por
cuatro y esto nos debe de dar 24 vamos a
ver si nosotros primero hacemos este
paréntesis tendremos que 3 por 4 es
igual a 12 y si 2 se lo multiplicamos
por 2 pues tenemos 24 vamos a hacer este
segundo bloque y los invito a qué pausa
en el vídeo y ustedes solos vayan viendo
que tenemos ahora el conjunto en azul y
luego tenemos el bloque en morado para
que ustedes solos lo vayan haciendo
asumiendo que han parado el vídeo
contaremos entonces aquí que tenemos un
bloque de 4
y otro bloque de cuatro dentro de este
conjunto morado así es que colocaremos
dos veces
tenemos conjuntos de cuatro pelotas o
dos por cuatro dos por cuatro este es el
primero de cuatro y este es el segundo
conjunto de cuatro haremos lo mismo aquí
tenemos un conjunto de cuatro dos
conjuntos de cuatro
es decir dos por cuatro y lo mismo
haremos de este lado
tenemos otra vez dos por cuatro ahora
nuestro gran conjunto púrpura tiene tres
de estos bloques uno dos tres grandes
bloques morados por lo que pondremos que
tenemos tres veces
la multiplicación de dos por cuatro
2 x 4 una vez 2 por 4 2 veces 2 por 4 3
veces tenemos 3 por 2 x 4 ahora esto nos
dará 24 también debería ver si nos damos
cuenta 2 por 4 es igual a 8 8 por 3 es
igual a 24 de la misma manera que
teníamos aquí pero se dan cuenta hemos
estado cambiando del orden de esto y más
adelante le daré los nombres elegantes
que se usan en las matemáticas para este
caso vamos a hacer este último bloque
los invito a que ustedes pausa en el
vídeo lo hagan sólo como lo hemos hecho
anteriormente y veamos si también nos da
24 asumiendo que pararon el vídeo y que
ustedes lo intentaron por su cuenta
ahora podemos ver que estos grupos sólo
contienen tres en la línea azul pero que
cada uno de nuestros conjuntos morados
contiene dos veces estos pequeños grupos
que están unidos por la línea azul así
es que tenemos uno por tres
2 por 3 2 por 3 de la misma manera aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 un conjunto de tres y este
será el segundo conjunto de tres dentro
del grupo morado dos por tres
haremos lo mismo aquí abajo 2 por 3 lo
tenemos en este gran conjunto morado y
una vez más uno por 3 y 2 por 3 2 por 3
cuantos bloques de 2 por 3 tenemos pues
tenemos 1 2 3 4
así es que colocaremos nuestra
multiplicación como cuatro por dos por
tres
y es decir tenemos cuatro grandes
conjuntos que tienen cada uno
dos grupos de tres pelotas verdes esto
nos debería de dar 24 vamos a ver si es
cierto 2 por 3 es igual a 6
6 x 4 es igual a 24 cada vez nos dimos
cuenta que tenemos como resultado final
24 y esta primer propiedad de las que
les hablaba va a ser la propiedad
asociativa qué significa eso significa
que si estamos multiplicando
dos o tres son más números entre ellos y
se están agrupando de diferente manera
no importa el orden de los mismos es
decir aquí tenemos dos por tres por
cuatro si se dan cuenta que tenemos tres
por dos por cuatro
no importa cómo estemos asociando estos
dado que todos nos darán exactamente el
mismo resultado aquí hemos asociado el 2
por el 3
aquí el 3 por el 4 y aquí el 2 por el 4
sin embargo los únicos números
constantes que hemos manejado son 2 4 y
3 así es que esta propiedad asociativa
nos indica que no importa como los
asociamos siempre vamos a tener el mismo
resultado y aquí lo hemos visto con 24
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo completamente
nuevo para explicarles la sociedad
conmutativa hicimos más espacio y ahora
les tengo otro ejemplo que qué tal que
ahora tenemos 4 por 5 por 6
ustedes pueden hacer algo pueden hacer
tal vez 4 x 5 y todo esto multiplicarlo
por 6
digamos que hacer primero 4 por 5 y
luego multiplicarlo por 6 o pueden hacer
lo siguiente que tal que ahora van a ser
primero 5 por 6 y después multiplicar
todo eso por 4 esta es la propiedad
asociativa que les decía no importa qué
es lo que asocien primero teniendo todas
estas multiplicaciones vamos a tener
exactamente el mismo resultado y los
invito a que ustedes resuelvan cuánto es
4 por 5 y después multiplicar eso por 6
o multiplicar 5 por 6 y todo ello
multiplicarlo al final por 4
esta es la propiedad asociativa ok y
tenemos otra en la que nos indica que no
importa el orden es exactamente lo mismo
si nosotros multiplicamos 4 por 5 por 6
que si multiplicamos
5 x 4 se dan cuenta como simplemente
alterne este número primero tenemos el 4
y luego el 5 y ahora tenemos primero el
5 y luego el 4 y lo multiplicamos por 6
o incluso es lo mismo si nosotros
multiplicamos 6 por 5 por 4 estoy otra
vez
alternando aquí primero tenía el 5 por 4
y ahora tengo primero el 6 esto se llama
propiedad conmutativa y nos indica que
el orden no nos está afectando en el
resultado tanto la propiedad asociativa
como la propiedad conmutativa son
nombres super elegantes para algo que es
racionalmente sencillo
la conmutativa nos indica que el orden
de nuestros factores no nos altera el
resultado mientras que la propiedad
asociativa nos indica que no importa si
hacemos primero cuatro por cinco
asociando estos dos números y al final
multiplicarlos por el que nos queda o si
multiplicamos primero cinco por seis
mientras los factores sean exactamente
los mismos números estamos claros nos
vemos en otro vídeo